impossible foods might be the world's
most ambitious company just listen to
founder and CEO Pat Brown people wonder
how big the plant-based meat industry is
going to be it will be the meat industry
in 20 years we're gonna look back and
basically say Wow
remember back in the day when we used to
use animals to make meat yes impossible
stated goal really is to replace the use
of animals as a food production
technology globally by 2035 that would
mean supplanting a 1.2 trillion dollar
industry not to mention a source of
sustenance as old as time to be fair the
company has got a lot of people talking
about its products so there's this thing
called the impossible burger what's
called artificial meat the realist
fakest burger in the world not bad but
before impossible foods can take over
the world it's going to have to overcome
strong competitors penetrate tough new
markets and generally transform its
product from a conversation piece into a
ubiquitous staple food with the
coronavirus turning the world of food
upside down this could be the moment
when Impossibles newfangled meat goes
mainstream
[Music]
impossible foods was founded in 2011
when pat brown a long time vegan was
nearing the end of an accomplished
career in biochemistry I've been a
scientist my whole life and just came to
this realization that by far the most
important scientific question in the
world is what makes me delicious Pat
Brown someone call a zealot for his
mission he really doesn't hold back when
it comes to talking about wanting to
completely replace animal agriculture
producing meat from animals is the most
destructive technology on earth and if
we're going to avert catastrophic
climate change until we have to find a
better way to produce meat you've
probably heard about the dangers of cow
flatulence their digestive systems
produce large quantities of the powerful
greenhouse gas methane in fact it's
estimated that livestock farming is
responsible for nearly fifteen percent
of all greenhouse gas emissions
impossible claims it takes 89 percent
less GHGs
87 percent less water and 96% less land
to produce its burger the key of course
would be to get people to actually eat
the thing which is where the company's
secret ingredient comes in heme a
genetically engineered substance with a
bloody iron-rich taste like red meat so
heme is a very controversial part of the
impossible burger it's also what makes
the impossible burger what it is there
are a lot of consumer groups and anti
GMO groups that oppose the impossible
burger because of the heme the studies
on its safety are pretty short-term but
the FDA has approved it and the company
says it's completely safe and there
isn't any evidence that it isn't
critics have also challenged the
company's claim to health advantages
over traditional meat pointing out that
while the impossible burger has less fat
sodium and calories than it's beefy
cousin it's also more highly processed
but let's be real we're talking about
mimicking hamburgers here not kale
salads these burgers are definitely
better for the environment so that's a
plus but they are not necessarily better
very healthy after years in the lab Pat
and his colleagues were confident they
had a product even Ron Swanson could
love and the impossible burger made its
debut in 2016
their burger began its life in the
public when it was sold at David Chang's
Momofuku and they went from sort of
higher and fine-dining restaurants into
higher-end burger restaurants like bear
burger and mommy burger and then
suddenly they started popping up
everywhere it tastes like a burger it
tastes like meat this is all made from
plants all made from this tastes like
beef doesn't just look real me
so meat like they always say it's like a
burger it tastes like yuckers be foes of
the world
relax that doesn't taste like a burger
opinions differed on the impossible
burgers relative meatiness but the
debate itself was fantastic free
advertising helping to propel impossible
into major chains like White Castle and
then in the summer of 2019 into more
than 7,000 Burger Kings across the u.s.
to date the company has raised over a
billion dollars and a funding round in
March valued the company at around 4
billion but fake meat is a happening
space these days and impossible faces
some daunting competition time now for
the stock of the hour and that is beyond
meat shares of the faux meat or
plant-based protein company are soaring
today beyond me is also making a very
meaty burger from plants they're very
non GMO they stress that all the time to
differentiate themselves from impossible
it'll be much easier to genetically
modify plant material to make it take on
the the texture and appearance and aroma
of animal protein we won't do that
beyond meat had one of the biggest IPOs
of the year in 2019 so impossible which
is still privately held has some
catching up to do but you won't hear Pat
Brown knocking his biggest competitor I
wish them nothing but success they have
the same mission we have the only rival
we care about is the incumbent animal
based industry rivals or not impossible
and beyond certainly agreed on one thing
the true prize isn't the American market
it's China
27% of the world's meat is consumed in
China compared to just 9% in the US the
Chinese population needs a ton of me
they're huge market China is a really
interesting case because they have long
had vegetarian cuisine as part of their
culinary culture and whether they are
looking for meat replacements is still
an open question what we found in our
reporting is that some consumers are
excited about them it's just we don't
know if it's gonna be enough to improve
its prospects impossible is developing a
plant-based replacement for pork
globally pork is the most widely
consumed meat it's almost 40 percent of
all the meat consumed globally number
one in Europe number one in China so if
we're going to achieve our mission pork
is you know right up there no word yet
on when impossible pork will be
available this morning growing concerns
about the nation's food supply from
butchers to national supermarkets
supplies now limited and prices rising
[Music]
the impact of the coronavirus on the
price and availability of meat has given
a boost to companies like impossible
foods over the four weeks ending April
19th sales of plant-based meat increased
but impossible has acknowledged some
negative effects from the pandemic as
well this being a product that has
primarily been served in restaurants
they took a pretty big hit with all the
food service shutdowns although the
company doesn't want to say you know how
much of a hit they have however
announced some new retail rollouts
recently they announced that they're
going to be rolling out with Kroger
supermarkets and that that's big that's
that's great for them the question of
whether this is like a long-term sea
change for these companies
stop doing see it's safe to say
impossible stands a slim chance of
achieving its goal of replacing the
entire meat industry but it's early days
for the science of plant-based meat and
it's not impossible that these products
could one day contribute to a greener
more humane future in the meantime as
the technology improves we get to look
forward to many more years of this this
is neat you know this is impossible yeah
that's what I thought this is a neat
burger right yes I like it better it's
not even close to a veggie burger or a
tofu burger hey wow that is very very
much over theirs tastes like a burger